ladies and gentlemen it is now
legal for you to paint a political
message that supports black lives matter
and if you paint over it that is a hate
crime we now have this breaking story
from kcbs 106.9
the martinez couple caught on video
painting over the approved black lives
matter mural
are being charged with a hate crime now
that's from the
uh contra costa county district
attorney's office
yep hate crime wow it is a hate crime
so so here's my concern first the the
mural was approved by the city
yep why is the city approving people's
right to paint on the street
yeah i don't understand it what pisses
me off is
uh we talked about this yesterday after
the show uh
you can burn an american flag legally
yep
but if you burn uh rainbow flags hate
crime that's a hate crime yes it is
how is burning an american flag not a
hate crime you are basically saying you
hate america that's not what hate crime
means
oh oh minorities right protected classes
protected classes yep so if you
if you burn an american flag they will
cheer for you and say free speech and if
you burn a rainbow flag they will say
hate speech
it's a hate crime so that's actually uh
because the argument is gorgeous
by burning the rainbow flag you're
intimidating a protected class
so there there is a difference though i
want to make sure i'm clear
in this in the specific case where this
came up it was because the guy burned
the rainbow flag and then threw it in
front of a gay bar i think
oh okay and so they argued that that was
you know intimidated intimidation
the however the argument is that people
routinely burn flags at public events
for people who support america and it's
not so there's got to be yeah
what's a bigger platform than the
internet now that is the largest
platform that we have access to
everyone has access to it so it's much
bigger than than
you know up one bar it reaches everybody
anyone can share it and
it can reach anyone so what's the
difference it's a hate crime
they're burning the american flag all of
them well either make it all the way
all illegal or none of it national
origin is a protected class
oh like american so then it is so if
you're if you're burning the american
flag specifically to make a point
to intimidate or shock people from
america which i'd argue makes sense
yep i'm pretty sure national origin is
uh protected you want you want to look
that up
national origin yeah i think it is 1966.
it's either it should either all
be legal or all be illegal i'm sick of
this hypocrisy it's ridiculous
that's liberalism the true definition
not the colloquial like the
you know i really hate when people call
the left liberals they are
not liberals they have not been liberals
for a very very long time i don't think
they know the true meaning of liberal
liberty knows tim well liberal uh is a
wide encompassing view that basically
means
uh government by the consent you know
through the consent of the governed okay
which means that the true definition of
the word it's why you hear people say
they're classical liberals okay
so this is a reference to like the early
american revolution conservatives
so uh the united states is what's called
a liberal democracy
it's not a reference to being leftist or
being a democracy
it's a reference to the institutions we
use democratic voting process
and liberalism in the sense that we we
give our consent to be governed
okay two varying degrees i know a lot of
people are like
i don't agree with taxes it's theft it's
like but we were born here in a system
that was already created so we can have
that argument but
typically you know western countries are
called liberal democracies
yeah the left is anti-liberal they are
ill-liberal
okay illegal meaning they don't believe
in free speech they don't believe in
individual freedoms
they don't believe that the consent of
the government is required for the
government to tell them what to do well
you could speak free
if you believe exactly the way they do
so this is this is actually listen
the the liberalism thing is all
uh it all makes sense these are people
who
believe that the world will end
because of climate change because
individuals refuse to adhere to the way
they see the world
so if if you know you got that aluminum
can right there
well why don't you use recyclable bamboo
bot you know cans or whatever or
something actually though
metal cans are are very very recyclable
oh but the recycling process produces a
ton of co2
if you used bamboo it could be
biodegradable i'm sure all of their
computers that they're tweeting on
are even more detrimental excuse me i'm
more effective this way
how dare you bigot i'm allowed to do
these things and you're not that's
illiberalism
right rules for thee but not for me i'm
seeing it everywhere
so they these people are like they
really think this way
i should be able to you know uh i should
be able to use computers
because i'm fighting to save the world
and if only these
other people stopped the world would be
saved yeah so they want to be the kings
so they can force you to live in a
bamboo hut with a loincloth and no
technology
they'll have the technology to make sure
everyone lives properly the way they see
fit yeah it's ridiculous
but that's literally what the far left
advocates for it is the opposite of
liberal
so right now you have i think you know i
i think it's funny whenever you see
people
arguing about what is or isn't the
factions of the culture war
okay and it really is just i love it i
really do love it first of all
one of the first things i heard is i
think it was milo yiannopoulos who said
this
it's authoritarianism versus
libertarianism you have the
authoritarian factions i want to tell
you how to live your life
and then you have the libertarian
factions who want to respect
individuality and stuff like that
i think that makes a lot of sense i do
too but then i've heard people say it's
no it's that's not true
it's the nationalists versus the
globalists and i'm like i
actually don't agree with that because
i'm not like an overt nationalist in
that sense but
maybe that makes sense a little bit i
mean everyone
everyone's different this is the issue
everyone wants to put everyone on this
like
each thing no no i mean everyone can be
different everyone can have a little bit
of aspects of everything it's like
it's it's whether you're you're letting
your emotions control it or
you know the logical side of it someone
else's definition of what the factions
of the culture were
is absolutely right and there's there's
different versions of that for every
single person we are
all different then when you listen to
the academic
intellectual dark web types they say the
culture wars between
groups with a post-modern world view of
subjective truth versus those who
believe in objective reality
okay and i'm like these are all kind of
true
right but it's like maybe that's just
not like one faction in one faction
maybe it's like
a an umbrella and an umbrella and
there's agreements
because like i don't base my identity
around nationalism
i do love america but i don't walk
around thinking like oh no they're
threatening to dissolve our borders and
stuff
my my thing is more about individual
freedoms respect
whether it's in this country or anyone
else's yeah you know cancel culture
extends to the uk i have friends in the
uk who are subjected to this stuff
but then there are people whose identity
is purely based on nationalism and
protecting america
and so we might find that we agree on
many issues
because of what america stands for yeah
and then their view is like here's what
cancer culture really is
ultimately what i think canceled culture
comes down to is
whether or not you believe in i i i
believe authoritarian versus libertarian
is the best way to view it
i really do because you know you end up
with like uh
dave rubin a gay married man classical
liberal
having a sit-down conversation with ben
shapiro an orthodox jew
where ben straight up says i don't agree
with you know how you live your life
and their friends having a conversation
in complete disagreement
and that that's what you know you can
see two people who
clearly are of different factions right
in agreement about
what's more important to them living
peacefully together versus what the
other side is trying to do to them
you know it's really interesting when
you look at there was a graph
charting clinton voters and trump voters
trump voters
were ideologically across the spectrum
except for social justice like
intersectionalism of course
clinton voters were clustered almost
entirely and so
among the trump trump's base you had
some people who are con
you had half conservative have liberal
on economic policy and cultural policy
when it came to hillary clinton it was
all it was like a huge far-left
cluster of intersectionality and like
racial justice stuff what a surprise
yeah yeah so i think that makes sense
trump won with a weird coalition they
did not expect he could pull off
oh man i saw a video today of all the
the pundits
talking about how it was a joke he's a
clown
i can't believe he's running no no no
trump
back this was like 2015. oh man it's
hilarious
one of the most classic clips is when
ann coulter was on bill maher yes
that exactly is like of the republicans
running now who do you think has a
chance to win and she goes of them now
donald trump and then everyone laughs
and she was she held her ground though
she was like
yep i'm serious like i was like man she
called it
everybody but pay attention to what
she's saying because she has not been
too kind to trump yeah
no no way yeah she's been tearing into
him so i have to wonder about some of
these higher profile people
who may be on in on the know and maybe
seeing some
some you know inner dialogue like you
know inner circle dialogues
what do they really know maybe trump
isn't going to win
listen man in 2016 i was like there's no
way they would let trump win well i
didn't vote in 2016.
a lot of people are telling me they
didn't vote ever
they didn't vote for many years doesn't
matter i'm hearing it all the time
thanks for standing up thanks for saying
that i've never voted but i'm
absolutely voting i'm absolutely paying
attention i hear you
you're right though it forced everyone
to be political to be into the
into this and i mean everyone's seeing
the crazy hypocrisy that's happening
from kovid
to the that's true you're not allowed to
go to churches
they're canceling church like really you
can't go to church you can't
you can't sing like i'm not i'm not very
religious but
man this is a free country and you
should you should be able to go worship
whoever you want to worship
well so the hypocrisy is driving me
crazy and i i know
it's driving a lot others crazy well all
that may be adam
yeah the one thing you're forgetting is
will they cheat
an election yeah yes well i mean i
every single time i look over that
ballot right there and then i think
about how biden's
making it a big deal that trump's going
to cheat trump's going to cheat
trump's like no no i'm going to i'll
leave like
no i'm good if i lose i lose and what if
they cheat
today's election how would we know
something let's how would we know that's
that's my question i'll tell you today's
election day
uh-huh the so uh i got uh
a primary ballot application mail-in
ballot application
okay i received no notice for what it
was for okay
i had no idea why i received it there
was no notice in the mail saying
here's a big explanation of what's
happening why it's happening it is what
you need to do
so one day i i see we have mail what is
it an official mail-in ballot sitting
right there
for someone who does not live here yeah
who didn't request one
i get an application i do live here
today's election day i didn't vote you
know why
i had no idea where to go and i couldn't
figure it out really well first of all i
have very little time throughout the day
you know i have a window of like two
hours after my first session that we
started preparing for this show
so once i finished i went to the website
where they were like here's where
all the information you need nothing was
there then someone said it's all mail-in
voting there's no there's no
uh ballot boxes anymore that leads me to
believe
we won't it's possible we won't see
record voter turnout
we'll see record low voter turnout how
many people are like i have no idea how
to do this
look man when i voted before they're
like
i i i i get wake up they'd beg its
voting day and then i would make a phone
call or go online but here's your voting
location i walk in
there's the sign i walk up now i can
vote yeah
today i have no idea what's going on it
should be it should be a holiday
well you can make that argument but the
point is i don't know where to go
yeah the website was down the website
didn't work
and so i was like i don't know what i
don't know what i'm supposed to do no
nothing i care about anyway
vote i guess vote in the democratic
primary yeah wait wait give me that
button right now
which one i need to hit that button we
have we have a special surprise for this
right now but you gotta hold it up to
the mic i will oh i will
[Music]
can i get my zoom in shot uh uh tim has
to do that one
oh yeah yeah yeah all right you guys
ready for this
someone sent us that dude
how dare i what not vote
so we we actually we actually need to
get the
the sound bar with with like the good
but somebody did this recording where
you press it
it's pretty good whoever said that to us
thank you that's amazing
how dare you button um we gotta get the
sound board going what are we doing
well we have priorities right now we're
we're about to move we're prepping and
moving i didn't i didn't know
what i was going to vote for anyway it's
it's the price primary day um
there's a couple people running for the
democratic primary in our in our
district i don't really care all that
much to be honest i
was like i would go and vote you know at
the last minute if i knew what to do but
considering it was like i don't know so
i guess i'm not gonna go
yeah so so my question is look
in 2016 i was talking to some uh
some personalities some finance
personalities who told me that
they thought because they were in europe
at the time
based on the media reports trump was a
clown joke that everyone hated
and they thought clinton had it in the
bag oh earthquake
i think you just hit the camera yeah
yeah you just totally knocked the camera
i didn't do that it's all good that was
a cat
can you uh perfect yeah you got it okay
so they were they were in europe at the
time
and they saw all the media reports
saying hillary clinton was
going to win yeah then they came back to
the united states actually landed
go this way left a little bit more
a little more now you're good well a
little less
so so hold on when they got here it's
fine okay when they got here they saw
the trump signs everywhere
and that's when they realized trump was
gonna win and then trump won
that point i think is interesting when
you bring up where when you drive around
here
this blue district yep it's like d plus
13 i think
you you drive around here and you see
all the trump signs i never saw
a biden sign i'll tell you that yeah
there's no biden science man all right i
saw trump signs
there's there's trump signs around the
neighborhood whoa
i wonder if like a biden sign is a rare
collector's item like it might be worth
money already
maybe so because i've i've never seen
one that's funny have any
has anybody listening seen a biden sign
i have not
i'm not i haven't i know i'm not a joker
trying to figure it out i'm like
no i don't know somebody planted a trump
flag in the lake by our house
no it's true and it's not a real lake
you can actually go on it's like a
drainage ditch yeah it's like a bog
yeah it's like a bog and somebody went
out there and planted a trump flag
yeah but the reason i brought up the
story for 2016 is that
even though there were people that were
like wow as soon as i saw that i
realized he'd win
my mentality the whole time was like
they'll never let him win i do not view
like the system as
i don't know fair these people these
people are all super wealthy
do nothing crony corrupt i view the
whole system as broken and corrupt full
of corrupt incumbents
yep and then something trump won a lot
of these old crony corrupt republicans
have retired or quit
you know like you know they're i'm out
just ditching it there's plenty of
democrats that have been around for
50 years yeah the system is just being
occupied by lazy do-nothings who are
just like it's you know the keys to the
castle no and they're
ranking in money from lobbyists and
stuff listen man sitting
changing laws for whatever they feel
like basically
trump wants to pull our troops out of
afghanistan yeah what's wrong with that
everybody's resisting it i cannot
imagine they would let him
win right you know whatever that means i
have no idea
but how could trump possibly win in the
face of a military-industrial complex
and crony politicians that are blocking
him from bringing our troops home
two words red pill
what do you mean everyone's getting red
pill people are are home
from covid they're not working they're
the democrats paying attention
exactly my point yes i know they did
it's gonna backfire everyone's at home
going what are the democrats doing
what's going on in these democrat cities
why would they do it
why because they do it because they
think that it's it's
like when bernie lost in 2016 right
the dnc knew that they took he took
hillary's voter base away from her right
so if bernie wasn't there
hillary might have won right it was a
higher much higher chance that she would
have won
if if the bernie supporters just if
bernie was never a part of the situation
right i think it's possible
no i know talk about the other day yeah
that's what i'm i'm referencing that
conversation you know we we talked about
that
so you know it's they started pandering
to the far left
that's yeah that's my point they started
pandering because they wanted that
grassroots they were like oh
maybe that is what works and you just
you just said you know
it's a big bubble of sjw's that that's
who her voter base was already
and then hillary clinton hillary clinton
right so i don't think hillary's was
no that's what you just said earlier
what do you mean when you were comparing
trump versus hillary
in the 2016 election and uh trump's
supporters were all over the place with
their ideologies whereas
hillary is it what trump the
conservatives have an ideology the left
didn't
no no but you were talking specifically
about hillary versus trump
and how all the trump supporters were
kind of all over the place but hillary's
supporters were all in this little
bubble
oh i'm referencing what you just told me
the democratic voters 20 minutes ago
so on the on the graph of economic left
and right yeah
trump's was both liberal and
conservative okay so now moving forward
now we're in 2020 they're going it's
election year
we need to whip up all these these gr
this grassroots
you know movement get black lives matter
you know there's this whole conspiracy
about the the act blue funding
you know that that's funding biden's
campaign you know it's like all this
stuff it's like they're leaning in
as hard as possible to try to get as
many of these
youth you know you you see pelosi saying
we should lower the voting edge to 16.
it's like
i'm 36 i didn't know who i was what i
was doing politically until
yesterday and 18 is yeah it's 18
i had no i had no clue it would capture
a lot of votes if they lowered it to 16.
i know and they know it voter turnout
among the youth is extremely low
right but it's still more votes from the
youth bracket if you get two more years
right so that's what i'm seeing i'm just
saying ridiculous that's what this is
all it's all them leaning in to try to
get as
to scoop in as many of these the sjw
group the the the minorities the the
people that
feel they're homeless you know what do
you got what do you got lydia i think
this would backfire on them because i
was reading a statistic
earlier about how high schoolers are the
most patriotic demographic
they don't change until they get into
college first yeah that's true
i saw that yeah interesting that was
really interesting thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you